plastic straw see they kill turtles they
kill women and restaurants stop using
plastic straws little turtle noses and
ladies ears hey I'm Bobby from Netflix's
queer eye and this is what happens next
alright let's see this one a both girls
fall over simultaneously be the guys
trousers fall down or see the guy jumps
and smacks his head on the roof
[Music]
I was wrong his trousers fell down yep
nope
next a the cat runs vertically up the
wall be the cat attacks TV causing it to
tip over or see a spider falls from the
roof and lands on the person holding the
camera wrong again
crafty little [ __ ] okay a the lady
sneezes and gets ketchup all over her
face ooh did she have a dinner of my own
but that's gross be a straw is blown and
lands perfectly in her hair it better be
a paper straw or we're gonna have a
problem see the lady turns to the camera
and her false teeth fall out no a
plastic straw see they kill turtles they
kill women and restaurants stop using
plastic straws little turtle noses and
lady's ears all right here's a girl
don't get much to go on it's still just
her with a stupid grin on her face so a
a light bulb falls from the ceiling and
lands on her wineglass be a while posing
and she'd look she lets out a fart let's
see the cameraman proposes to her my
girlfriend was let's say what would I
have won if I had won
that's not what you promised me if I won
I've been looking for the D all day and
I haven't found it